in the year 2054 mind control technology
has become widespread resulting in an
extremely changed society for a good
price humans now have the liberty to
control other humans and make them do
inhumane jobs at the heart of the
controversial technology is its creator
billionaire ken castle famous for his
mind control games society and slayers
the first game society is a virtual
community life simulation game it is
similar to the sims but instead of
controlling a fake character the gamers
can control real people and make them do
whatever they want this is a win-win
situation for all people those who are
looking for some fun can splash some
money and make others do their work
while those who need money can simply
become a society avatar and get paid the
game received such critical acclaim that
castle became the richest person in the
world in a matter of weeks move over
fortnite several months later castle
created another game slayers this
controversial first person shooter game
is a simulation that gives the players
full control of a human being allowing
them to act out their most savage
fantasies online in front of a global
audience the game uses real death row
inmates as avatars who are offered the
chance to participate as an alternative
to their death sentence the convicts who
can survive 30 battlegrounds are set
free although no one has ever achieved
this feat yet which is good because
setting them free makes no sense cable
is the crowd's favorite in this game
having survived a record 26 matches no
inmate has managed to last more than 10
before him he is exclusively controlled
by simon a young pro gamer from a
wealthy family the two continue to
emerge victorious from every single game
defying all odds next we see ads of the
game everywhere and how cable only has
four sessions left to achieve freedom
despite being a notorious criminal
people are rooting for him to win at one
of these alive telecasted battlegrounds
cable faces off against other players in
intense gunfire each character earns
points for saving a teammate and killing
the opponents there are also other
people on the battlefield who are tasked
with doing menial jobs like sweeping
cleaning and so on these people are
seemingly unaware of the violence around
them as expected cable manages to
slaughter everyone during the fight in
the next scene the tech savvy
billionaire and computer programmer ken
castle is interviewed by popular tv host
gina parker at first gina introduces
castle and his inventions to the
audience castle invented
self-replicating nanites that replace
brain tissue and allow humans to control
other humans actions and see through
their eyes then both of his
record-breaking games society and
slayers are promoted castle mentions
that while society is a source of income
for many people slayers focuses more on
the entertainment aspect the inmates
aren't paid a dime but whatever money is
generated from the live streams is
donated to fund the prisons and other
public infrastructure this is why the
u.s federal government has given full
support to slayers gina asks him about
the other people who do menial tasks in
slayers and castle replies that they are
called genericons they are sent into the
slayer's environment with pre-programmed
actions with no one controlling them and
no way to react genericons are basically
like npcs in games if someone is
shooting near them they won't run and
will simply carry on with their tasks
although they only have to survive one
game to earn freedom their chances of
survival are next to nil after the
interview an activist organization
called the humans hacks into the show's
display system and a man calling himself
human's brother claims that castle's
technology will one day be used to
control people against their will
hearing the broadcast people become
intrigued but before heeman's brother
can reveal anything else castle's men
locate its source and shut it down
elsewhere at the prison cable sits alone
watching fellow prisoners playing
basketball he thinks about his family
but is soon interrupted by another
inmate named freak freak wonders how
cable has managed to successfully pass
27 matches leaving only three to get his
freedom he also asks how a person like
cable ended up in prison in the first
place although the latter doesn't reply
he gets a flashback where a man is
bleeding to death and he can find room
back in his cell a woman drops a picture
of cable's wife and daughter and asks
him to sign a paper she explains that
her son david is a big fan of cable and
wants an autograph when he comes closer
to ask about the picture the woman takes
his blood sample claiming that it would
prove his signature to be authentic
elsewhere cable's wife angie goes to
work as a character in society in the
game the characters are dressed in funky
costumes angie's character is controlled
by an obese man called george who makes
her talk to a man with a pig nose the
man starts to grope and kiss angie but
her attention is on her husband's banner
across the street suddenly human's
brother hacks the society's system and
continues to condemn castle meanwhile
the prisoners are taken to their next
battlefield as soon as they arrive a
brutal fight erupts several of them end
up dead from gunshots truck accidents
fire explosions and other gruesome ways
meanwhile cable notices a woman
pre-programmed to walk over the
battleground unaware of the violent
environment around her simon has cable
save the woman from a truck accident and
bring her over to a corner of the street
however when cable is distracted by his
opponents the woman again walks up to
the street and is run over by a truck
there's only so much you can do to save
a lemming despite the setback cable and
simon eliminate all the opponents one by
one and eventually emerge victorious
seeing this people from all around the
world erupt in joy next we finally get
to see simon who is a rich spoiled brat
with the latest technology at his
fingertips while lying on his bed simon
orders online upgraded ammo for cable
and also chats with some girls suddenly
his feet is hacked by humans who shows
him footage of cable shooting a man in a
confined room this is the reason why he
became a prisoner as simon watches in
shock the anonymous group asks him if he
wants to talk to cable the scene then
abruptly cuts to castle who is ready to
introduce a new inmate hackman into
slayers the plan is to kill cable before
he wins the two remaining games and
leaves the prison unknown to anyone else
hackman will not be controlled by a
player and thus not be handicapped by
the ping that causes a small but
dangerous delay between the player's
command and the slayer's action later as
freak and cable are talking about their
lives they noticed the terrifying
hackman freak reveals that hackman
murdered a group of people and turned
himself in in the next game cable is
stunned to find simon communicating with
him since avatars and their controllers
can't talk to each other it turns out
that the humans hacked into the system
to make this possible soon the battle
ensues and simon uses the live stream as
an advantage to guide cable while
dodging gunfire and targeting back the
opponents cable notices that freak who
is volunteered to be a generic on is
sweeping the street sadly he ends up in
the crossfire and gets shot dead shortly
after as cable is searching the
perimeter hackman arrives at the scene
and savagely attacks him he then
proceeds to finish cable off but
fortunately the game's timer runs out
much to the relief of simon meanwhile
angie applies to get custody of her
daughter delia who has been placed with
a wealthy family the caseworker denies
the application reminding angie that her
job is a character in society and cable
as a convicted murderer isn't going to
guarantee safety for their daughter
elsewhere as simon is upgrading cable's
armor he is again hacked by human's
brother the latter reveals that with
only two games remaining until freedom
castle is planning to kill cable so they
have to get him out immediately he then
urges simon to relinquish control of
cable during the game and after a lot of
convincing the teenager finally agrees
back in prison cable is contacted by the
same woman from before who informs him
that simon will be letting go of control
during the final battle and if he wants
to see his family he needs to escape
cable immediately agrees and tells the
woman that he needs to get drunk before
the battle on the day of the final
battle cable suits himself up with a
bulletproof vest he notices a bottle of
vodka in his suit and drinks it in one
go in the battleground cable gets
heavily drunk and frequently stumbles on
the ground witnessing this simon scolds
him to get on his feet if he wants to
stay alive until their escape plan after
a while cable goes to a garage forces
himself to vomit in an ethanol gas tank
of a truck and then pisses in it
surprisingly he can now start the truck
because of the ethanol in the vodka
however just before he drives away
hackman clings to the door of the truck
and attacks cable the two struggle for a
while but cable eventually manages to
escape by slamming the beast into a
pillar on the way several guards and
cars chase him but cable manages to
evade every single one of them after
causing some of the cars to crash into
each other he finally gets out of the
slayer's perimeter but just as he exits
the truck and starts running a missile
lands near him and throws him away
fortunately he is left unharmed
meanwhile the broadcast of the game is
stopped prompting the audience to
believe that cable is dead but the tv
host gina who is also watching the game
is positive that cable is still alive
that evening cable goes to his apartment
but cannot find his wife there because
he hasn't met angie since he was
imprisoned he doesn't know that she
currently works as an avatar in society
as he sits alone a woman from the humans
group approaches him she introduces
herself as trace who is the same woman
who contacted him in prison she then
takes cable to the human's headquarters
there human's brother tells cable that
they took his blood sample earlier to
crack the nano code which made it
possible for simon to talk to him he
adds that castle isn't willing to set
him free so they helped him escape the
humans wants cable's help in bringing
down castle before everyone can become
his slaves initially cable is
uninterested in helping out but when he
learns of angie's current location in
society from them he agrees on the other
hand the escape plan has put simon in a
difficult position he is labeled a
cheater locked out of his gaming account
and investigated by the fbi for helping
cable escape inside society angie is
being harassed by a man in a hotel room
when the man forces her to bend down
cable arrives in the nick of time and
rescues her however as the two are
preparing to leave hackman emerges from
the elevator shoots cable in the chest
and takes angie away luckily cable is
still wearing his bulletproof suit and
he doesn't sustain any injuries he then
finds hackman and an intense fight
ensues this time cable gains the upper
hand and blows off one of hackman's legs
with a gun shortly after the couple
reaches a place where several society
characters are dancing even there cable
is pursued by castle's men who open fire
aimlessly just when it seems as if cable
and angie are about to be killed gina
approaches them in a car and helps them
escape it turns out that she is also a
part of humans and takes them to their
headquarters there the group deactivates
the nanites in angie and cable's brains
and the latter remembers that the
original nanites were tested on him
while he was still in the military
but he still hasn't regained full memory
human's brother then examines cable's
brain and discovers that he was already
under castle's control even before he
was imprisoned it turns out that he
became one of the first test subjects to
try out the new technology sadly castle
tested it to an extreme causing cable to
shoot his own friend this is why he was
imprisoned later angie apologizes to
cable that she couldn't get custody of
their daughter just then trace arrives
and reveals to the couple that the
wealthy father who adopted delia is none
other than castle himself upon learning
this an enraged cable decides to finish
castle once and for all that night he
infiltrates the billionaire's mansion
and finds his daughter however he cannot
reach her as it turns out to be a
projection on the wall after a while he
locates castle he starts explaining
about his recent invention controlling
several people at the same time he also
shows a demonstration by controlling his
men and assigning them to attack cable
fortunately cable manages to fight them
all off castle then reveals that while
cable came looking for him his men
tracked down the humans headquarters and
killed all of them he also reveals that
98 of his own brain has been replaced
with nanites but this allows him to
control others rather than be controlled
furthermore he shares his ultimate plan
to release airborne nanites which will
infect the entire united states within
six months giving him the ultimate
control then castle takes cable to a
basketball court where hackman is
playing on the ground he then takes
control of hackman and assigns him to
attack cable with a knife thankfully
cable manages to break his hands and
snap his neck twice to kill him cable
then tries to attack castle but he is
frozen in place it turns out that the
bad guys have already reactivated his
nanites allowing castle to take control
over him in the meantime unknown to
castle gina and trace have escaped the
slaughter on the human's headquarters
dead set on revenge they broadcast
cable's nano code to the world showing a
live feed of what he sees this exposes
castle's plans and the entire world
turns against him immediately back at
the mansion cable who is now fully under
castle's control gets badly beaten after
this the vicious billionaire orders his
men to bring out angie who is captured
alive from the humans headquarters and
their daughter delia castle then tries
manipulating cable into killing his own
daughter cable who still has a little
bit of control can resist but not for
long fortunately elsewhere simon gets
his account unblocked after he gains
public favor again he immediately
restores control over cable and guides
him against castle now with the battle
being two against one cable slowly
points the knife at castle as the two
fight for the knife cable tells castle
to imagine being stabbed castle
unconsciously does so allowing cable to
kill him and removing his control over
everyone with castle dead the audience
cheers for the demise of their potential
slaver and dictator cable then convinces
castle's technicians to deactivate the
nanites from everyone freeing all the
characters in society and slayers the
movie ends with cable angie and their
daughter taking a family trip down the
road
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching